يواصل مراقبوا الملاحه الجويه في فرنسا
اضرابهم عن العمل اليوم الثالث عشر على
التوالي من المتوقع ان يؤثر الاضراب اليوم
السبت على الرحلات في مطرايبورد وتولوز
جنوب غربيه البلاد قد طلبت المديريه العمل
الطيران المدني الفرنسيه من شركات النقل
الجوي الغاء نحو 20% من رحلاتها كما طلبت
المديريه من الشركات الغاء نحو 25 من
الرحلات المقرره لاحد بمطارات باريس اورلي
وبورد وتولوز هذا ويطالب المضربون
المراقبون المضربون باسقاط قانون التقاعد
الجديد
المثير للجدل
باريس ينضم الينا مراسلنا حافظا ربح حافظ
حجم تاثير اضراب مراقبي الملاحه الجويه
حتى الان
نعم في الحقيقه هذا الاضراب هو محدود
التاثير هنا بحسب مراقبين وايضا بحسب ما
قالته المديريه العامه للطيران المدني هنا
في فرنسا يذكر ان هذا الاضراب انطلق منذ
نحو اسبوعين تقريبا احتجاجا على قانون
التقاعد الجديد وعلى الرفع من سن التقاعد
القانوني من 62 عاما الى 64 عاما منذ ذلك
الوقت يتواصل هذا الاضراب بنسق اعتبر
منخفضا نسبيا حيث لم تشهد المطارات حاله
وقف للرحلات او غير ذلك ولكن الامر كان
محدودا حيث بقي في حدود 20
25% تقريبا من الغاء الرحلات اليوم مثلا
مديريه العامه للطيران المدني طلبت من
شركات الطيران التخفيف من رحلاتها بنسبه
20% في من مطارات مطاري بوردو وايضا ثلوج
غدا الاضراب سيشمل مطارات اخرى من بينها
مطار باريس اورلي هنا في العاصمه باريس او
ايضا مطار بالاضافه الى مطارات بوردو
وتولوز هي في الحقيقه هذه الاجراءات التي
تطلب من خلالها الاداره العامه للطيران
المدني من الشركات ان تخفض في النسق او
نسبه الرحلات او عدد الرحلات الهدف منه
التقليص الى اقصى حد من الاضطراب على
الرحلات الجويه ولكن رغم هذه التدابير
تتوقع الاداره العامه
للطيران المدني ان يحصل بعض التاخير او
الاضطراب هنا وهناك في الرحلات يذكر ان
هذا الاضراب سيتواصل ايضا يومي الاثنين
والثلاثاء وسيشمل بالاضافه الى المطارات
التي شملها فيما قبل سيشمل ايضا مطار
مرسيليا يذكر ان كل هذا الاضراب يؤثر ايضا
على حركه الطائرات التي تمر من الاجواء
الفرنسيه وهي طائرات لا تنزل او تقلع
بالضروره من المطارات الفرنسيه ولكنها
تعبر الاجواء الفرنسيه طبعا كل هذا يعود
الى الاحتجاجات المتواصله على قانون
التقاعد الجديد نعم باريس شكرا جزيلا لك